The second option is what we call an experimental study. Hidden in this one
sentence are aspects that are universal to all experimental studies we do in
psychology. Let's start with caffeine in varying amounts. Every experiment we
do, we have to manipulate or change something or else we cannot make a causal
statement from our result. So whatever it is that we manipulate or change is
our independent variable. So in this case caffeine is our independent variable
or iv for short because we're changing the amount of caffeine each group gets.
An easy way to remember this is investigator starts with an i. An independent
variable also tarts with an i and it's the investigator that manipulates the
independent variable. And we measure the effect of our independent variable on
the dependent variable. The dependent variable in our experiment is reaction
time because a dependent variable is what we measure. We need to measure how
the dependent variable responds or changes to the independent variable. So how
does reaction time change when we manipulate caffeine? In order to make a
causal statement, we need to make sure that the iv or the independent variable
is what causes the change in the dependent variable. So in our case, we need to
know that caffeine is what actually causes the change in reaction time.